and my first semester freshman year I
chose my my schedule based entirely on
workload in other words the lowest I
could find
let's just say I was bored out of my
skull because there may have not been a
lot of quote unquote homework but the
professors were dull as dishwater and
boring and my grades actually weren't
that great either because I wasn't
engaged and so the next semester I
learned the lesson which is it's not
about the workload it's about the
professor and so I picked my entire
course load based solely on the
professor even if the workload was
through the roof
and I had a blast because the professors
were amazing and I was engaged and I was
interested and curious and so now if I
look at how I've navigated my career
since I was entry level I've always
tried to pick the people because I
recognize that working for a great
person great leader is going to have
better long-term effects on my joy my
inspiration my performance so yeah I've
worked very hard to choose who I work
for not necessarily make decisions based
on money or workload